hey John uh hey John so the other day I
was just walking down Centro is trash he
says guys always in here just telling me
I'm not good enough you look like you
look like Drake's
ugly cousin Derek can argue with that
I'm not good at a lot of things most
things some would say here's a list of
all the things I'm good at
versus all the things I'm bad at I'm not
good at sports I don't know how to make
pottery I can juggle I'd make a terrible
doctor just give it to me straight doc
how is she well if we're being honest I
don't think she's gonna make it no if
we're being really honest your shoes are
whack and you smell really bad
of what like I could smell you when I
walked into this room like maybe it's
best if she died so she won't ever have
to smell you again whatever we're gonna
have to run a couple more tests to be
sure and adult nevermind she's dead I
can't do a good Kayne impression but I
can do a good impression of Obama doing
a bad Kayne impression now easy easy
easy just jumped over jump me okay were
you I don't know Michelle there's no Kim
it was just a video even with the things
I think I am good at I always feel like
I'm not good enough there's always that
tiny little voice in my head that's like
you called that a good grade you call
that being a good friend you call that a
creme brulee you call that a flashback
if you think I'm bad at this then why
don't you just leave no I know you're
bad I just need you to know you're bad
my problem is if I'm not amazing at
something I just tell myself what's the
point of even doing it like if I'm not
an amazing singer why sing at all why
would anyone want to listen to me when
they can listen to Adele or Shawn Mendes
um crazy prog Oh the thing is the only
way you can be amazing at something is
if you practice but I don't want to be
at that first level where I'm trash at
it I just hate feeling like the most
unqualified person in the room which is
why I feel so uncomfortable in my
yes was class all of them it's all I
still vividly remember being a small kid
in art class and another kid who was
just sitting in front of me out of
nowhere just turns around and says this
poor helpless fool trying to draw his
measly giraffe as I complete my replica
cafe terrace at night by Vincent van
Gogh
I wish death upon you and your family
yes I hope you die class look at this
let's all laugh that was all probably in
my head what actually probably happened
was he just turned around and said well
Nathan that looks pretty good and then I
started thinking that looks good
he's lying he hates it he's taunting and
I have to kill him before he kills me I
wish I had an answer for this problem of
not feeling good enough but I don't uh
it's something I go through every day
still what I'm trying to do right now is
just do things just do things I love
regardless of how good I am and just not
care what's that quote you miss 100% of
the shots you don't take
shut shut them a basketball not a ball
and don't don't drink alcohol and play
basketball or you miss 100% of the shots
you do take see your life is like
rolling hogar you're gonna try making a
food metaphor a burrito you got all
these things are good at you on saying
you got your rice you got your beans
you got the succulent chicken the
lettuce the sour cream the guac
it's the money right eating them
separately you might not have the best
chicken in the world or the greatest
sour cream you ever tasted you might not
be incredible at this you might not be
amazing at that but roll them all
together and make you you got a pretty
good burrito person ah nailed it
oh hey he's gone I guess I learned to
overcome it that's what you call that
character art kids that storytelling
that's brighting get me on a show that's
my time here I hope you enjoyed that for
more food based inspirational metaphors
follow me on my youtube or my twitter at
Nathan's ed I just noticed I'm wearing
this but this is very appropriate uh the
Cowardly Dog the cowardly human